[Music]
there's no place like home and that's
why we're celebrating as many hometowns
as we can all across the country all
season long
next up is portland oregon where
culinary professional judy ann wu calls
home i hear she makes it her mission to
know all the best restaurants and chefs
in town now that's a woman after my own
heart let's watch
hey drew it is caramack host of k2's
afternoon live your sibling show in
portland oregon and i know you are
celebrating hometown spirit well no one
has more hometown spirit than our very
own julianne moon judy and share with
people what portland's so awesome
portland is my hometown and love it so
much there are so many amazing places to
eat and drink plus scenic beauty and the
most passionate and creative people you
will ever meet and you're gonna show it
off for everyone so we're gonna send you
off have so much fun
welcome to omsi omg stands for the
oregon museum of science and industry
it's got something for everybody you
learn about the earth the universe and
everything in between
we have here giant australian walking
sticks this is one corner of the museum
where they have actual live creatures
that you can interact with such as these
say hello to drew
i'm here at toki restaurant in the heart
of downtown portland and behind me is
chef owner peter cho
he's doing his take on the most
delicious crave-worthy korean-american
classics this is like you know portable
food
so good yes
well drew that was just a quick peek at
portland the city we love so much we
can't wait for you to come visit see you
soon
hey drew my name is tatianae i am an
elementary school teacher right here in
washington dc now uc has been my home
for the past couple of years and i love
it here one of the things that i love
about dc is its rich history culture now
about to go check out union market it's
my favorite place to hit up right after
work so let's go
my first stop when i come to uni market
is i always go to pudding pudding is a
new orleans southern comfort food all
wrapped in one honestly the bread
pudding is delicious but everything on
the menu is delicious i've normally
ordered the shrimp and grits or the
souffet so if you're at new market check
out pudding
we're here at meridian hill park what's
the locals actually calling my friends a
little no [ __ ] i didn't even know it was
called meridian hill park i've always
referred says malcolm x park now on
sundays they have a drum circle and it's
absolutely beautiful like live music on
a sunday why not it's my favorite place
to come when i just want to chill out i
want to walk my dog go for a run it's
just the peace in the middle of a city
all right drew that's just a little
snapshot it's the washington dc i hope
you love it as much as i do listen next
time you're in town hit me up girls i'll
see you soon
howdy drew i'm pam minnick here at ktvt
cbs 11 in fort worth dallas texas along
with chief meteorologist scott padgett
and what we love about this area of
north texas is the perfect blend of
cowboys cowgirls culture and
entertainment now we're headed to see
the dallas cowboys because cbs 11 is
your official cowboy station
we're at the home of the cowboys dallas
cowboys football team that is and my
favorite part of the team are the dallas
cowboy cheerleaders who have a message
for you drew welcome to a t stadium
how about those moves drew you know even
when it's not football season you've got
to see the cowboys stadium the size the
scope of it the artwork the memorabilia
it's worth seeing
[Music]
this is the national cowgirl museum and
hall of fame in fort worth texas where
women who shape the west with their
can-do spirit are recognized and i'm
proud to be one of those honorees dr
diana vela what makes the cowgirl museum
a must-see we are the only institution
in the nation that honors those women
who are shaping the west and changing
the world where else can you see miranda
lambert's guitar a game of thrones
saddle and annie oakley shotgun in one
place well drew that's just a little
taste of what makes fort worth dallas so
special i hope you love it as much as i
do and i can't wait for you to visit you
know they say that everything is bigger
in texas so i can't wait to show you
more
[Music]
you